وضع النساء في افغانستان لا يزال ويتصدر
لعناوين في ظل الاخبار القديمه من هناك
اخر التطورات التي عادت لتضع اوضاع المراه
الافغانيه تحت المجهر في حادثه القتل التي
ذهب ضحيتها نائبه برلمانيه سابقه الامر
يتعلق بالنائبه السابقه مرسالنا بزاده
والتي كانت واحده من عضوات البرلمان
القليلات التي قررنا البقاء في افغانستان
رغم صعود الطالبان الى السلطه في اغسطس من
عام 2020 فيما يتعلق بدوافع الهجوم ف
تليفون الروايات حسب مصدرها حسب زعمي
قائدي الشرطه التابعه لحركه طالبان مولى
في حميد فان حارسا ثالث من مكان الحادث
ومعه نقود ومجوهرات ما قد يوحي بان الامر
يتعلق بجريمه جنائيه في المقابل اوضح بعض
انصار مرسالنا بزاده ان السياسيه الشابه
كانت تلقى التهديدات بالقتل بسبب حملاتها
لدعم حقوق المراه وفي نفس السياق اكدت
عضوه البرلمان السابقه مريم سليمان خيل
عبر تغريده لها ان النبي زاده كانت بطاله
لا تعرف الخوف وامراه قويه لم تتخلى عن
مبادئها وبقيت تواجه الاخطار ما قبل اربعه
اشهر ظهرت مرسال على شاشه التلفزيون
المحلي منتقده قيود طالبان على حريات
المراه سيام القرارات الاخيره مثل منع
النساء من ولوج الجامعات او منعهن من
الاشتغالي داخل المؤسسات اجنبيه